what happens if the Earth suddenly stops
rotating and a thing that isn't attached
to its surface remains at its initial
speed not just cars buildings and people
but also water and our atmosphere
causing giant tsunami waves and Global
windstorms areas near the equator where
the Earth's rotational speed was the
fastest would be affected the strongest
there everything would continue to move
forward at 1 600 kilometers per hour
don't forget the long-term effects over
billions of years centripetal forces
have made Earth a bit wider at the
equator without rotation these forces
would vanish oceans would migrate to the
poles which are closer to the Center of
the Earth and have stronger gravity so
we're left with dry land around the
equator also our usual day night cycle
would cease to exist without rotation
one day lasts one year with six months
each of daylight and darkness and
Earth's magnetic field which is partly
generated by the rotation of our planet
might be altered once the Earth stops
rotating as a result we might face
higher exposure to deadly solar
radiation quite dramatic changes in case
you've ever wondered